[Music]
hey what's up guys I'm Kay PhD here and
yesterday I was actually in New York for
the US launch of the Galaxy Note 2 but
more interestingly the Samsung Galaxy
camera I spent a lot of time just on the
side of the event I know the focus was
on the note but I was just really
intrigued by this camera and to be
honest it really impressed me I really
liked it a lot so without any further
ado let's go ahead and take a look at it
so here it is on the front of this
camera it looks like your typical
high-end digital point-and-shoot pretty
sweet 16 megapixel sensor 23 millimeter
wide angle lens with 21 X optical zoom
but when you turn it around back it has
a sick 4.7 inch HD Super AMOLED display
full screen with Gorilla Glass 2 it's
just slightly smaller in footprint than
the galaxy s3 for reference but that's
just in height and width on the left
hand side there is a mechanically
operated flash pop-up button which works
flawlessly of course and on the right
hand side there is a standard microUSB
charging port and on inside is 8 gigs of
internal storage but of course on the
bottom here you can see it's expandable
via a microSD card and right next to
that is your SIM card slot and an HDMI
port and of course the tripod mount and
also down under is the battery in this
guy which is a 1650 million power
battery it seems a little bit small I
don't have a lot of hands-on time to get
that to see the battery drain but since
you'll have to keep it on 4G when you
don't need to it should last you awhile
but obviously turning on that boss
display you get a full-fledged shrunken
Android tablet in here I don't say
Android phone because while it does have
a mic it doesn't make phone calls but
it's basically a smaller tablet and it's
running Android 4.1 jelly bean behind
the scenes but while it is indeed
Android 4.1 it's obviously not stock
Android and Samsung has to make some
serious improvements to make it a
full-fledged camera and they actually
did a great job with that and most
notably inside the camera app it is a
really impressive app here you can dial
and adjust manual controls like shutter
speed and aperture and all the way open
to F 2.8 and ISO all the way up to 3200
with previews in real time if you're
feeling lazy you don't have to use all
these manual controls you can flip it
into automatic
and let it do all the work for you or
you could even enable some of these
interesting filters to get some cool
effects outside of the Instagram app
which can actually be used on this guy
so in terms of image quality by itself
from what I can see on the screen stuff
look pretty sharp and noise performance
in the dark was actually decent which is
a good sign
it also takes 1080p video at 60 frames
per second so that's nice and as to meet
video modes like slow-mo capture etc
it's basically the camera app on
steroids just for this device and I like
it and feel free to give a thumbs up
below if you do too so there you go guys
that's the Samsung Galaxy camera it's
available later this year and for an
unknown price so I'll keep you guys
posted on that probably on Twitter at
mkbhd I think it'll be really good at
the gatherings and sort of party
scenario where you're taking photos and
videos and sharing them as you take them
which is kind of like the real-time
sharing that Google+ sort of started
it's kind of an interesting product I
would definitely like to see more
hands-on with it and I'll be giving you
guys some test footage and some test
videos of the actual camera sensor so
you can get get a sense of how good that
is as soon as I get my hands on it's a
thumbs up if you're excited for that if
you want to see it compared to some
other cameras but otherwise that's
basically it so thanks for watching and
I'll talk to you guys the very next
video
[Music]